it was that darn kitten again.
All this is enabled
because we were able to find a way
to translate a very hard problem
to something our brains do very naturally.
So what does this mean?
Well, for kittens, it means
no more hiding in ones and zeros.
For me, it means no more wasted weekends.
For cyber, it means we have a radical new way
to tackle the most impossible problems.
It means we have a new weapon
in the evolving theater of cyber warfare,
but for all of us,
it means that cyber engineers
now have the ability to become first responders
in emergency situations.
When seconds count,
we've unlocked the means to stop the bad guys.
Thank you.
(Applause)